[Musique]
bonsoir entonne ce faire merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france la
répression alimentée par le made in
france c'est la formule que l'on
retrouve clairement sur le site
d'amnesty international qui accuse donc
paris on l'a entendu de contribuer aux
violences à hong kong et en fournisseur
d'armes votre réaction à ces accusations
de l'omg
en premier c'est de masse tout ce qui se
passe au liban spécialement céder les
geôles à tripoli dans le nord du liban
il ya des problèmes majeurs des
problèmes de santé de des problèmes et
de pauvreté
il ya la qualité des services publics
qui est en état de désarroi
il ya tout un système qui s'écoule pas
de contrôler la justice sociale n'existe
plus
tout ça a engendré une certaine
révolution pacifique 7 et le 19 le le 17
octobre 2019 actuellement ite problème
qui enquête commencée deux nouveaux dans
les villes de tripoli et qui peuvent
être vraiment généralisée dans tous les
toutes les régions du pays vu que les
problèmes sont toujours là que les
problèmes de sociaux c'est-à-dire il ya
des gens qui n'ont plus de quoi manger
c'est un grand problème il n'y a pas de
solution en vue il ya toujours des
discours des choses qui sont pas qu'ils
sont faits qui ne donne plus rien pour
compatriote libanais le citoyen s'avère
vraiment bel essai c'est pour cela
actuellement il ya un
vous voulez une équation de force des
vents violents de tripoli entre les
forces de la sec de sécurité intérieure
et les les citoyens les manifestants le
problème ici c'est dommage qu'un
investisseur international qui est qui
n'est pas une organisation ou du ciel
mais c'est une organisation
c'est une organisation
non-gouvernementale internationalement
reconnu et quelques indique qu'elle a
qu'elle a décrit la situation au liban
de cette façon si depuis 2015
ça ne veut pas dire que tout les toutous
les fêtes qui qu'on a vu dans le rapport
de la richesse nationale sont blessés il
ya une certaine véracité des choses qui
doivent être faites par via une enquête
l enquête que les pouvoirs imany au plus
ou plutôt des organisations
internationales ou même libanaise
indépendants qui doivent le faire afin
de sauvegarder en premier les libertés
publiques en seconde la crédibilité des
forces des forces de la vie et des
institutions libanaises
car je sais c'est c'est un peu
stupéfiant que les forces
militaire libanaise sont des gens les
ports et les citoyens de même sont ordre
le problème c'est que les pouvoirs
politiques libanais met les pauvres dans
une état dans un état de guerre
tant que la tandis que le business
politique c'est-à-dire toute cette
classe qui a gouverné depuis détester
continue dans le même pas cours pas de
contrôle et toutes les solutions sont
caduques
y'a pas un balle roule d'assainissement
public c'est pour cela les gens enfermés
sur la question est bien compris mais
justement sur la question de d'amnesty
international en gros vous vous
reprochez entre guillemets à cette ong
de s'appesantir voilà sur finalement la
responsabilité de la france dans la
distribution d'armes au liban poteau de
s'occuper entre guillemets des problèmes
profonds du du pays c'est ce que vous
êtes en train de de nous dire parce que
justement il ya quand même des
manifestants qui sont blessés avec des
armes vendues par la france en tout cas
selon amnesty international bien
évidemment ça ne vous choque pas vous à
titre personnel en tout cas ça me choque
en premier ça me choque toute sorte de
violence tout acte de violence de toute
sorte
eh bien je vois que je ne le crains rien
ne signale à quiconque il ya un grand
problème dans le pays est actuellement
il y a dejan des actes de violence de
balai d'eau
le problème c'est que en tant que
catéchistes juridique et dans les droits
de la personne moi je suis contre tout
acte de violence perpétré par quiconque
les choses doivent être pacifiquement
pacifiquement résolues d'une façon
humaine civilisé cette façon si n'est
pas acceptable ni de mal ni d'autre on
veut pas des manifestants qui sont qui
vont au delà du système juridique c'est
contre la loi c'est-à-dire et de même
qu'on veut pas les forces de sécurité
qui peuvent me l'idée des actes violents
avec des armes français ou autres
provenant d'autres pays comprenait des
gens civil qui l'ont parka kaki sont des
amis vous savez il ya c'est un grand
problème c'est grand dilemme c'est un
grand dilemme c'est dommage que le liban
pays liberté démocratie s'était classé
cessé d'écouler du score jusqu'au
jusqu'au bout dans cet état et on voit
des des photos ou à des événements ou à
des discours des gens le discours public
c'est à dire qui est vraiment kiki qui
nous sort si tu me choque
clairement aujourd'hui ces manifestants
vous dites il ne faut pas que non plus
hors du cadre juridique mais est-ce
qu'ils ont le choix vu la situation on a
parlé de ce triple problème avec pam
socio économique
à cela s'ajoutent les restrictions en
raison de la crise sanitaire quel est le
choix aujourd'hui pour la population
quelle marge de manoeuvre dont tout le
bas être mal compris moi je suis avec la
révolution
je suis avec les gens les manifestants
qui disent non à tout ce processus de
mendes politique qui a volé les
générations d'ibanez depuis trois 3 4
des ch'ti je suis avec mais il ya une
petite minorité entre les manifestants
qui utilisent des armes contre les
forces de sécurité et contre l'eire mais
ça c'est pas acceptable car ça c'est
contre la loi mais la manif des
manifestations doit continuer pas
tripoli dans tout le liban
le système ne peut pas continuer de
cette façon si c'est un système
d'appauvrissement qui n'est plus
crédible ni devant son peuple ni devant
la la communauté internationale c'est
pour cela les manifestants n'ont pas le
choix ils sont pas ils n'ont plus de
quoi vivre c'était vraiment c'est une
haine pour le liban c'est une haine pour
le liban mais a appelé mir
on veut pas on veut pas aller jusqu au
complot c'est à dire jusqu'à jusqu'au
déclenchement d'une nouvelle guerre
civile ou des troubles sécuritaires
de toutes sortes on n'a pas les moyens
on abat on n'a pas les nerfs qu'on n'a
pas la qualité de faire des troubles
sécuritaires vous savez la qualité de
vie au liban n'est plus la même c'est
pour cela la dernière question en train
de faire qu'attendez-vous du pouvoir
aujourd'hui
moi j'attends que tout ce que
l'international a dit tout ce que les
autres les organisations internationales
qu'ils à propos du liban protestent de
la situation à propos de l'utilisation
des armes qui ne sont pas un qui n'est
pas acceptable suivant le droit
international et donc je suis je tiens à
coeur car je suis spécialiste dans ce
domaine il faut respecter les droits de
la personne et dans la dans la
d'expression de la liberté et dans le
service et leur qualité de vie
c'est pour cela le pouvoir libanais doit
faire une enquête imminent afin de
donner une crédibilité à tout ce qui se
passe sur le plan politique et
sécuritaire sinon et je doute fort
quelques que le pouvoir à ce souci je
doute fort
la violence ne peut engendrer que la
violence ici le pouvoir apaiser les gens
par la violence ça peut pas aller ça va
engendrer beaucoup de troubles et de
soucis qui pourront perdurer pendant
peut-être des moins des années si des
solutions fermes ne sont pas là merci
beaucoup antoine sfeir avocat à paris et
beyrouth d'avoir été avec nous pour au
vu de l'extérieur ce soir